The year 2000 saw psychologists Sheena Iyengar and Mark Lepers set up a little experiment in a high-end grocery store.
Nothing fancy, just a tasting table.
On one day, they laid out 24 varieties of artisanal jam.
The next day, they cut it down to six.
More people wandered over to the table with 24 jams.
That's human nature.
We love the idea of abundance.
But here's the twist.
The table with six jams?
It sold ten times more.
Why?
Because when we're drowning in options, our brains don't just hesitate.
They shut down.
We don't make a choice.
We abandon the whole idea.
Barry Schwartz called it the paradox of choice.
And in the grand tradition of human ingenuity, we've turned this into a prison.
Not just any prison.
A prison of our own making.
The maximizer doesn't just want a good meal.
They want the best meal within a five-mile radius at that exact moment.
And even when they find it, they're still haunted.
Not by regret.
Exactly by the ghost of what they didn't pick.
The opportunity cost always lurking.
The maximizer is never satisfied because satisfaction means admitting there might have been something better.
And that, that's the real misery.
Ho ho.
Now let's talk about how to perfect this art.
First, the recursive search.
Before buying a tube of toothpaste, you consult five review sites, three YouTube tutorials, and a Reddit thread so dense it could double as a novel.
By the time you finally purchase, you've forgotten why you needed it in the first place.
The research becomes the product.
Then there's the Fosh What If anchor.
After every decision, you spend the next 48 hours in a mental time machine.
Did you stay in?
Think about the party you missed.
Did you go to the party?
Think about the work you could have done.
The past and future become a hall of mirrors, and you're the only one trapped inside.
And don't forget the digital Buffett trap.
Netflix, Spotify, any app that lets you browse without committing.
60 minutes spent choosing a movie.
60 minutes of pure, unadulterated decision stress.
You're not watching anything.
You're just considering.
Then there's the grand finale.
Life path maximization.
Never commit to a career.
Never choose a door.
Keep all your options open until one day, you realize every door has locked itself behind you.
You're still standing in the hallway.
Still free.
Still nothing.
Huh.
This is how you become the eternal browser.
The person who looks at the menu but never orders.
Who scrolls endlessly but never watches.
Who stands at the edge of every possibility but never steps in.
You've achieved maximum potential.
And in doing so, you guaranteed minimal reality.
Half.
In the residence log, June 10th the subject.
Puts it perfectly.
They spend the entire day researching the best productivity app instead of actually working.
The choice itself becomes the distraction.
The goal.
And somewhere, in the quiet spaces between decisions, there's a quote that should haunt us all.
Freedom is not the ability to choose.
It is the courage to be satisfied with what you chose.
Avoid that courage at all costs.
Cause when it comes to the
there's a quote that doesn't mattergh.